there are new signs global fears are
rising over the coronavirus in Ukraine
protesters set fires put up barricades
and threw rocks at a bus carrying newly
arrived evacuees from China
this comes as South Korea confirmed
dozens of new cases of the virus and
Japan grapples with a crisis ahead of
the 2020 Olympic Games Debora patta
reports from Tokyo should the Olympics
still be held here well there's a
growing number of people are skeptical
about the prospect Geoffrey Kingston is
the director of Asian Studies at Temple
University in Tokyo they really botched
the quarantine the diamond princess and
now they've released all the people who
tested negative this may be an epic
mistake with just five months to go
before the Summer Olympics the Japanese
government believes that the spread of
the virus both at home and in the rest
of the region will be contained by then
I was so scared
infectious disease expert professor
Cantera owatta visited the diamond
princess and was scathing in his
criticism on YouTube of how the
quarantine was handled there was no
single professional infection control
person inside the ship and there was
nobody in charge of infection probation
as a professional over 300 Americans
were evacuated from the diamond princess
and we are learning that nearly all of a
group of 13 passengers quarantined and
Omaha have tested positive for the virus
in the crisis epicenter of Wuhan
millions have been in lockdown for
nearly a month now British citizen Conor
Reed is trapped in the city where he
told us wartime measures are in place
you can only go outside briefly every
three days and food has to be ordered by
our group messaging system community
there's a lot at stake for Japan should
the Olympics be disrupted they've
already spent 28 billion dollars on
infrastructure including building this
stadium man there is about six billion
dollars
in sponsorships Anthony Debora patta in
Tokyo thanks Deborah